it's got to be bigger than i don't think
that's what it is i think obama i think
i think what you said is one i think to
obama
uh you know it's do you think relevance
and legacy matters to him
i think he may be the coolest
cat we've had as a president
i've ever seen minus reagan remember
what i said i didn't say
a policies you ever seen obama lose his
mind
have you ever seen obama flip out smooth
maybe maybe four times five times the
entire eight years i don't think i've
ever seen him
i don't think i've ever seen obama angry
where he snaps
in a way where some of these other guys
have snapped i don't think i've ever
seen any
any time that take place obama doesn't
if obama wants to do whatever obama
wants to do
obama's gonna obama was at a point right
now young guy he's still got a lot of
living to do he's going to stay relevant
he can do whatever he wants to do people
are going to want to participate huge 16
yeah so
he's not even 60. he had to remember
that's going crazy yeah i i don't think
he's
sitting there worried about if he's
going to get another project this has
simply got to come from a point of
okay um
i've done what i've done but can you
imagine because think about it this way
the whole story of lawrence miller the
book barbarians to bureaucrats that
every
society goes through a few different
phases you got the prophet you got the
barbarian
which profit in this setting would be
who the founding fathers
barbarians would be who the industrial
revolution the soldiers that went out
there and they fought for freedom it's
okay that's not him
lincoln and teddy roosevelt builders and
the explorer you put rockefeller jp
morgan chase
carnegies that's the builder and the
explorer then he got the
administrators administrators are who
the lawyers let's put some laws together
right
so it starts with eisenhower right so
then you got so that's taxes 1913 right
1906.
that's when uh sec you know you got all
that other stuff that comes in 1913
taxes federal income tax starts at the
end of world war one so
so then after that you have the
bureaucrats and aristocrats
that's the last phase and you know what
happens when you get the bureaucrats and
aristocracy
then comes the fall we are at the
bureaucrats and aristocrats phase
here's the part if obama if president
obama wants to be known as the synergist
synergist that brought it together if
there will there will only be one in
this area there won't be six synergies
if you want to be a synergist
where you bring it together you have a
level that you go to that you're in a
league of your own
that's all there is to it because right
now so his legacy is one of division
there's no way that he can a lot of
people will say that but a lot of people
will say that about trump as well you
can just say it on one set a lot of
people will say
let's see what i'm trying to say is both
of them will be able to say look
set aside the money i don't even care
what you do with the money i want you to
give it to the following charity here
but
you know et cetera et cetera great hey
maybe they'll they'll even contact me
and they'll say if you get to 200
million dollars we'll do it i'll go
raise the money
i don't have a problem with the money
whatever the number is we'll go raise
the money if they want to happen
and maybe we'll even do this that it's
official we're doing and we're going to
give the money to
whoever the charity may be we'll pull
that off that is not a challenge to do
but a synergist is a permanent
legacy that will be talked about for
hundreds
and hundreds of years that is a very
very unique place to be
bring it to the lowest level bring it to
the lowest level let's go to the lowest
lowest level okay
people are texting me right now saying
pat i will put a half a million dollars
right now i'll put a quarter million
dollars right now these are friends of
mine that are business people say this
guy
i will put up a hundred thousand dollars
right now for that interview okay so
that's individual chats what's happening
here
i i'm who's putting money on us i don't
know what's going on here let me go back
to my point here tom
so so to go back to this thing you uh
synergist senator jefferson one
synergist yeah so okay go back to your
family go go back to your family
go to your family and think about
the two relatives that nobody could have
brought them together
who are the two relatives no you don't
need to say the names but you know
exactly what i'm talking about oh yeah
every family has them here's a question
did they ever come together it took a
death
who brought them together the death of
my grandmother that okay it took the
death of a grandmother took a death okay
so the death could be what the fall of
an empire oh yeah okay sure so do you
remember yours you don't need to say who
it is but
did that ever happen your family yeah it
was my
parents getting married and they both
have told me what happened and who was
there
it was amazing and so the marriage
brought them together the wedding itself
brought them together but then at the
reception no bad words were spoken but
they went their ways so my mom and dad
said they'll never be in the same room
together once they got a divorce
from from july 15th they were in the
same pew in the front row together
for 60 minutes for the wedding and
everybody was shocked and afterwards
they were very polite but they left
my so just your point so july 1589 we
escaped iran that was the last time my
mom and dad were in the same room
together
but when they got a divorce my mom said
i'll never be in the same room as your
dad my dad said they'll never be in the
same room with your mom
i said great no problem i'm getting
married so they're coming so we haven't
got an invitation
that's because you're not invited yet
they said what do you mean we're not
invited so you think the first time
you're going to meet each other
at my wedding do you think it's a
one-room wedding yeah so i said you
think
i said the only way you're invited to
the wedding is if you guys are willing
to sit down and have a conversation take
it a moment that came together
at my house they spent three hours
together after
20 years of not being the same room and
then i said are you guys
able to do this we can then we did my
wedding pictures running every time i
look at the what do you call it the
family wedding pictures
you see the picture there it's so every
time i watch it i crack up because
nobody knows the
politics behind it to me i look at my
dad's face in my mom's face
it's only two faces i look at when i
look at that picture right there's
classic
the point is this in every family
someone unites
i call it the dog mentality diffuse
unify glue diffuse unify
glue diffuse unify glue you have to
diffuse the issues that we have today
in order to unify and be the glue glue
brings people together
the media is the complete opposite is
divide
divide divide that's all they do
whatever they can do that impose
conflicts against each other is divide
divide divide
we want to diffuse we want to unify we
want to be glue
if these guys were to come together it
wouldn't be for the money
i agree if they have a number that they
want us to raise and make this happen
we'll go out there make it happen
i don't even want this thing to be some
people call me they said you're probably
going to go sell this on pay-per-view
you're going to go sell this to abc
you're going to go sell this to this
that's what i don't want to do matter of
fact i'll even do it in a way to not
even monetize this for people to realize
this needs to happen this is not about a
monetization type of a stuff this is we
need to have this thing to become a
reality if you want this thing to happen
let's go out there and do it i want to
see this happen because i'd like to look
back and say okay
look in reality who has more experience
when it comes down to
the the stuff that happens at the u.s
government us
trump or obama oh my god trump obama
trump
okay great well let's come on down let's
sit down here's how i see it
when i process this the reason why i
haven't announced it for the last five
weeks what's the week before fourth of
july july you'd say june 28th
so june 28th today is what exactly four
weeks right it was a saturday
saturday or sunday sunday we had a
gathering for i don't know what what it
was about
matter of fact no i'm sorry it was a
week before brooklyn was born so it was
like july
june 20th or something baby shower at
the house i don't even remember what the
date was for that
yeah was it mid-june it's got to be six
weeks ago anyway right before
it was before that because i was still
in uh dallas and you called me tom what
do you think of
this and this is this and i said let's
process this i love the idea i'll see
you next week it was in your old place
in boca
yeah you had the whole team over there
and then things were kind of settling
down and
you know we were like dude you're about
to have your fourth kid man you were
like man you had like this moment of
like reservation like i i hope that she
has the same country that my other kids
are growing up in
and that's and that's when i was like
well okay yeah this is these are tense
times for sure man
and you were like okay what can i do i'm
gonna bring i'm gonna bring obama and
trump together and we were like uh
okay how are you going to do that no no
i'm going to do it uh
i i i i thought about it and here's what
i thought about so if this happens
china's going to have a few steps back
to take
okay uh number two you know you know
what i'd like to see happen with this
first we do the
the discourse the civil discourse for
them to go back and forth i think
neither one of them is scared of the
other one i know
i think obama's up for it and i think
trump is definitely up for it
i think neither one of them is sitting
there saying i will never you know i
think it's more the only reason this
people
talk circles around trump i think i
think i think the only people that will
not make this happen is the people
around them
it's the only people i think trump wants
to do it i think obama would love to do
it
and i think you know what i'm most
excited about this here's what i'm most
excited about this
this is what would make my day if this
were to happen say they come down they
have a conversation together
okay here's my favorite part afterwards
is for them to go and spend a couple
hours just by themselves with nobody
being around
just talk no one to be around i got a
playground
no no no and i'm being serious right now
no no
camera no audio no nothing no fan base
no advice around your side no advisor on
the other side just the two of you
talk sometimes you got to talk about
yourself to the person that's your enemy
and just sit down and say whatever the
hell you want to say that's not on
camera what do you want to tell them
talk to each other i i i see that being
way way way less likely than the actual
hang on
i don't i don't know i don't i don't see
it less likely let me let me
let me interrupt go back and look what
happened to camp david peace accords
they took a break and without their
handlers they were all going to take a
break and just go
amongst themselves carter over here
begging over here set out over here
but bagan and sadat took a walk through
the woods
it's not really woods it's paths at camp
david together without their handlers
and without the media
and they say that there were
breakthrough elements on that walk
and it was away from the cameras pat i
don't know if you've been studying this
or anything but what you're saying
history shows it's correct history shows
it right a little time together
one-on-one
would facilitate and it happened i don't
think that it wouldn't
i just think i can't see the handlers
letting it happen i can't see the teams
letting it happen
we live in a time guys buildback better
is everywhere
but a year before they broke it they're
going to build it back better they're
the ones that broke it but they're the
ones that would do it
they're the ones that would do it if
there's any two people that would do it
as a two of them
like you know it's it's like it's like
go play
around the golf with nobody just secret
service outside but nobody
can hear your conversations go spend a
couple hours together
what does the world do if they see these
two guys golfing 18 holes nine holes
they've experienced something only 40
other people on earth have ever
experienced
being they've that's it 43 others that's
it
right so yeah so absolutely but at this
point
again this is the part i does does obama
think for himself or is he afraid of
what other people tell him what to do
does obama is you think obama's going to
be the person that's going to say
hey don't say that obama and obama's
like okay i'm not going to say it i i
think there are elements of that yeah
i don't know i disagree i think obama
knows what he's all about i think
as far as as far as maybe some things
that will not work in the campaign i
agree
don't wear this tie wear this you know
that kind of stuff of course
he's going okay you're the expert in
this area you think someone's going to
be able to say hey
don't say that policy or this or that
you know okay i'm so sorry i'm not going
to do that i don't i think he's going to
do what he's going to do
and i think trump's going to do what
trump's going to do heck we know when he
was president nobody could tell him what
to do some of the stuff he would do
you're like
that was not good i think obama if obama
was completely autonomous he would have
extended the bush tax cuts
i don't think so if obama was autonomous
would have been completely autonomous
would he have
extended the bush tax cuts but that was
that was a part of his
message he felt the solution was to
raise taxes
he felt that was the solution i don't
okay that's how he extended the bush tax
cuts that's i'm not
so what i'm saying is i i don't i don't
know if
i i i see barack obama
[Music]
i see donald trump less this way but i
see barack obama more as the the front
man of a team
than as a an individual driving force
uh i don't know i see differently i see
i see
he's at a phase of his life did you see
his interview with letterman did you see
his interview when he did letterman
have you seen some of the stuff that
he's done after presidency i've seen all
this work
and he looks like a kind of guy that
just wants to have us fun and live his
life
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]